Before you came into the world of radio, what were you doing? I was working on wacky daytime talk shows, late night talk shows, YouTube talk shows, a bunch of just random things. My colleague at 99% invisible, Vivian Le. On the 2013 reboot of the Arsenio Hall show, I was a production assistant and my current fiance was also production assistant and we've been together for five years. So last year Vivian had to plan her wedding, which was kind of like her old job as a production assistant. Except that in this production, she's the star and the wardrobe department. I've been looking at wedding dresses since me and
在你进入广播界之前，你是做什么的？我当时在做一些古怪的日间脱口秀、深夜脱口秀、YouTube脱口秀，还有一堆乱七八糟的事情。我的99% Invisible同事，Vivian Le。在2013年重启的《Arsenio Hall秀》中，我是一名制作助理，我现在的未婚夫也是制作助理，我们已经在一起五年了。所以去年Vivian不得不筹备她的婚礼，这有点像她以前做制作助理的工作。只不过在这场制作中，她是主角，也是服装部门。自从我和
Cody got together. Five years ago. Yeah, like I've always looking at wedding dresses since me and Cody got together. Five years ago. Yeah, I've always been thinking about what kind of dress do I want. So I think that's probably why it's so hard for me to decide now, because it's something that I've been thinking about for so long. It's a really big decision. So I'm not really looking forward to picking out the dress, because it seems so stressful. I mean, on the surface, it's just a dress.
Cody在一起后，我就一直在看婚纱。五年前。是的，自从我和Cody在一起后，我就一直在看婚纱。五年前。是的，我一直在想我想要什么样的婚纱。所以我认为这可能就是我现在很难决定的原因，因为这是我思考了很久的事情。这是一个非常重大的决定。所以我并不是很期待去挑选婚纱，因为它看起来压力太大了。我的意思是，从表面上看，它只是一件衣服。
A dress that is white. But you like buying clothes normally, no? I like, oh, this is really bad. I am a, I'm like a bargain shopper. I am a Maxineista. Like TJ Maxx? Why is that bad? Because I buy a lot of clothes that you would not think
一件白色的衣服。但你平时喜欢买衣服，对吧？我喜欢，哦，这真的很糟糕。我是一个，我像是一个折扣购物狂。我是个TJ Maxx的忠实粉丝。像TJ Maxx？为什么那很糟糕？因为我买了很多你不会认为
highly of after doing articles of interest that are very cheap. I could like, you know, buy a ton of them and like, oh, whatever, it's just like $5 for the shirt. So I'm that kind of shopper. I think of like, what kind of value can I get for this? And I feel like a wedding dress is never equated with value. Most people I think spend more than $1,000 on their wedding dress.
在做完《Articles of Interest》之后会觉得很高级的廉价衣服。我可以，你知道，买一大堆，然后觉得，哦，无所谓，这件衬衫才5美元。所以我就是那种购物者。我会想，我能从中获得什么样的价值？我觉得婚纱从来不与价值挂钩。我认为大多数人在婚纱上花费超过1000美元。
And that sounds insane to me. I would rather not spend more than like eight hundred dollars on a wedding dress. Eight hundred dollars to me is a lot, but if you like... That is a lot. It's a lot of money. So when are you going wedding dress shopping? Oh, I'm putting it off so much and I don't want to do it. And it has nothing to do with me not wanting to get married. It's that it's so much pressure
这对我来说听起来很疯狂。我宁愿在婚纱上花费不超过八百美元。八百美元对我来说很多，但如果你喜欢……那确实很多。那是一大笔钱。那你打算什么时候去买婚纱？哦，我一直在拖延，我不想去。这与我不想结婚无关。而是因为压力太大了
to spend so much money on this one item of clothing that I know I'm only gonna use once. Da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da. Articles of interest, a show about what we wear. Season 2. People don't realize it's fantasy. It's always this thing that you have to work extra hard to get. Mmm, that's so good. No one dresses like a king anymore. How do you make money?
要在这一件衣服上花这么多钱，我知道我只会穿一次。哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒。《Articles of Interest》，一个关于我们穿什么的节目。第二季。人们没有意识到这是幻想。这总是那种你必须付出额外努力才能得到的东西。嗯，太棒了。现在没有人像国王那样穿衣服了。你是怎么赚钱的？
That's how we make money, love. There are lots of things that we take for granted that would once have been considered luxuries. A wedding should be pretty simple and straightforward. It's just about you and the person you're marrying and the ones you love and it should just be that. At least, this is Vivian's fantasy. I don't want to spend so much time getting ready
我们就是这样赚钱的，亲爱的。有很多我们认为理所当然的事情，曾经被认为是奢侈品。婚礼应该是非常简单直接的。它只是关于你和你结婚的那个人，以及你爱的人，它就应该只是那样。至少，这是Vivian的幻想。我不想花那么多时间准备
for my wedding. I just kind of want it to be a much time getting ready for my wedding. I just kind of want it to be a nice dinner with my friends and family. We want like a five minute ceremony, like so people don't have to sit through reasons why we love each other, because whatever. You can understand why maybe lots of couples would at least be tempted to escape from that burden. Dr. Benjamin Carney is a professor of social psychology at UCLA and the co-director of their marriage lab. He has talked to a lot of couples. Almost every couple I've ever talked to
我的婚礼。我只是希望它是一个花很多时间准备的婚礼。我只是希望它是一顿和朋友家人共进的美好晚餐。我们想要一个五分钟的仪式，这样人们就不必坐着听我们为什么爱对方的原因，因为无所谓。你可以理解为什么很多情侣至少会受到诱惑去逃避这种负担。Benjamin Carney博士是加州大学洛杉矶分校的社会心理学教授，也是他们婚姻实验室的联合主任。他采访过很多情侣。我采访过的几乎每一对情侣
has said in planning their wedding, we strongly consider trucking it all in a loping. Most couples don't do it. Most couples have their wedding and some couples do, and they lope. That has some benefits. You save the expense. You save the money.
在筹备婚礼时都说，我们强烈考虑过私奔。大多数情侣没有这样做。大多数情侣举行了婚礼，有些情侣确实这样做了，他们私奔了。这有一些好处。你节省了开支。你省下了钱。
And you can spend it on yourselves. You don't have to worry about your family's interacting. I would say it also has some costs. Because what you don't get is the public display of couplehood. And that is what a public wedding is all about. Letting other people invest in your partnership. A wedding does something to the couple. It also does something to the guests.
你可以把钱花在自己身上。你不必担心家人的互动。我想说它也有一些代价。因为你失去的是作为情侣的公开展示。而这正是公开婚礼的全部意义所在。让其他人投资于你们的伙伴关系。婚礼对情侣有影响。它对客人也有影响。
If I attend a wedding, I was there at the, you know, the institutional beginning of your relationship. And that means I'm kind of responsible for you. That's a heavy thing. It's not just a party. And that pressure quickly changed all of Vivian's wedding plans, which had started simply enough. So I'm getting married in Italy, in the summer.
如果我参加婚礼，我就在那里，你知道，在你们关系的制度化开端。这意味着我某种程度上要对你们负责。那是一件沉重的事情。这不仅仅是一个派对。那种压力很快改变了Vivian所有的婚礼计划，这些计划最初很简单。所以我要在夏天去意大利结婚。
This was last summer, by the way. And it was just supposed to be a small destination wedding, family-only. But two Americans can't legally get married in another country. So Vivian decided on a courthouse wedding in LA and invited her friends. But then her fiance's family on the east coast got wind of that. Cody's family was like, okay, we'll throw you a party and we're like, okay, great, yeah. So we checked back in with them. There's 150 people coming and they run to
顺便说一下，这是去年夏天。这本来应该是一场小型目的地婚礼，仅限家人。但两个美国人不能在另一个国家合法结婚。所以Vivian决定在洛杉矶举行法院婚礼，并邀请了她的朋友。但后来她未婚夫在东海岸的家人听到了风声。Cody的家人说，好吧，我们给你们办个派对，我们说，好吧，太棒了，是的。所以我们回访了他们。有150人要来，他们租了
out this beautiful hall with a view of Manhattan in the background. So now we're having three weddings, yes. Three different weddings with three completely different locations. And I know a few couples who have done this, who've had a handful of ceremonies to accommodate everyone they love. And of course, this affects the dress, because you will wear different outfits to a courthouse or a church or a beach or Disney World.
这个美丽的礼堂，背景是曼哈顿的景色。所以现在我们要举行三场婚礼，是的。三场完全不同的婚礼，地点完全不同。我知道一些情侣这样做过，他们举行了几场仪式来照顾他们爱的每一个人。当然，这会影响到婚纱，因为你在法院、教堂、海滩或迪士尼乐园会穿不同的衣服。
It depends on the weather, it depends on how big the space is or how formal or informal it is. And this dizzying array of options is a byproduct of a wealthy post-industrial civilization. For the lion's share of history, brides just got married in whatever they had that was nice and clean. They might have one fancy dress for their wedding, and then they might wear that same dress again for all the other weddings they attended as a guest. And this dress often wasn't white. A very deep purple velvet, and it's very richly embellished with gold metal thread embroidery. Curator Heidi Rabin showed me a purple velvet
这取决于天气，取决于空间有多大，或者它有多正式或非正式。这种令人眼花缭乱的选择阵列是富裕的后工业文明的副产品。在历史的大部分时间里，新娘只是穿着她们拥有的漂亮干净的衣服结婚。她们可能有一件漂亮的婚纱，然后她们可能会在参加其他婚礼时再次穿上那件衣服。而且这件衣服通常不是白色的。一种非常深紫色的天鹅绒，上面有丰富的金线刺绣装饰。策展人Heidi Rabin给我看了一件紫色天鹅绒
caftan covered in gold embroidery, depicting flowers and trees. It was a wedding dress from the 19th century Ottoman Empire. This garment is called Abindali. And this is a garment that was very typical for a Turkish and Ottoman Turkish Jewish woman. It was considered part of her dowry. So when she would get married, this was a very valuable piece of clothing that she wore at the wedding, but also at the ceremonies leading up to the wedding, and then also for any very important parts of her life thereafter. Imagine you'd be getting married in your Bindali surrounded by all your friends in their Bindalis that they were married in. It must have been quite powerful. It would be like being accepted into a coven.
上面覆盖着金线刺绣，描绘着花朵和树木。这是一件19世纪奥斯曼帝国的婚纱。这件衣服叫Bindali。这是土耳其和奥斯曼土耳其犹太女性非常典型的服装。它被认为是她嫁妆的一部分。所以当她结婚时，这是一件非常有价值的衣服，她在婚礼上穿，也在婚礼前的仪式上穿，之后在她生命中任何非常重要的时刻也会穿。想象一下，你穿着你的Bindali结婚，周围都是穿着她们结婚时穿的Bindali的朋友。那一定非常震撼。就像被接纳进一个女巫集会一样。
Or like a robing ceremony for an academic or a judge. Yeah, I think that's about welcoming someone into a community. Heidi is the senior curator at the contemporary Jewish Museum in San Francisco. Last year they hosted a show called Vailed Meanings, which displayed some wedding dresses from across the Jewish diaspora, which displayed some wedding dresses from across the Jewish diaspora, which is to say, from across the world, primarily from the Middle East, North Africa and Central Asia.
或者像学者或法官的授袍仪式。是的，我认为那是关于欢迎某人进入一个社区。Heidi是旧金山当代犹太博物馆的高级策展人。去年他们举办了一个名为“面纱下的意义”的展览，展示了一些来自犹太侨民的婚纱，也就是来自世界各地，主要是中东、北非和中亚的婚纱。
And a lot of these wedding clothes from this huge cross section of the globe were worn multiple times, or at least twice. This garment was actually a burial shroud. Heidi shook me this caftain-like tunic made of linen. And the burial shroud would be worn during the wedding from both men and women, and it was a way of reminding people that this very important moment in their lives of their mortality. So, on the two most significant days of your adult existence, you'd be wearing the same
这些来自全球各地的婚纱中，有很多被穿过多次，或者至少两次。这件衣服实际上是一件寿衣。Heidi给我看了这件像长袍一样的亚麻束腰外衣。寿衣在婚礼期间会被男人和女人穿，这是一种提醒人们生命中这个非常重要的时刻与死亡相关的方式。所以，在你成年生活中最重要的两天里，你会穿同样的
thing. This was common in several different parts of the world in the Jewish faith in particular. Of course, now, each wedding dress is a decidedly one-time thing, and it's not a community dress. The bride wears white, and usually she's the only one wearing white. It is all about her one dress on this one day.
东西。这在世界各地的几个不同地区，特别是犹太信仰中很常见。当然，现在，每一件婚纱都是绝对的一次性用品，它不是一件社区服装。新娘穿白色，通常她是唯一穿白色的人。这一切都是关于她在这一天穿的这一件衣服。
And sure enough, the exhibit at the Contemporary Jewish Museum, like a lot of fashion runway shows, and like this podcast series, ends with a big white wedding dress, as a finale. To reflect on this trend of wedding dresses being white. Note how Heidi called it a trend. Yes, white has been a marker of maidenhood and virginity for centuries, but the white wedding dress trend began when Queen Victoria married Prince Albert in 1840.
果然，当代犹太博物馆的展览，像许多时装秀一样，也像这个播客系列一样，以一件巨大的白色婚纱作为压轴。反思一下婚纱是白色的这种趋势。注意Heidi是如何称它为一种趋势的。是的，白色几个世纪以来一直是少女和贞洁的标志，但白色婚纱的趋势始于1840年维多利亚女王嫁给阿尔伯特亲王时。
She wore white. And 14 years later, in 1854, Queen Victoria and Prince Albert staged a reenactment of their wedding so they could be photographed. Images of Queen Victoria's white dress circulated throughout the colonies in a way few images could. Her empire extended very long and very wide, and so the trend of wedding dresses beginning to be white, starting with her, really pervaded all over the world following that moment. It's a simple origin story, and simultaneously a massive and complicated one. Through imperialism, a look became a trend and became a tradition.
她穿了白色。14年后，即1854年，维多利亚女王和阿尔伯特亲王重演了他们的婚礼，以便他们可以被拍照。维多利亚女王白色婚纱的图像在殖民地以极少有图像能做到的方式传播开来。她的帝国延伸得非常长和非常广，所以从她开始的白色婚纱趋势，在那一刻之后真正遍及了全世界。这是一个简单的起源故事，同时也是一个巨大而复杂的故事。通过帝国主义，一种外观成为了一种趋势，并成为了一种传统。
It has to be white, or it doesn't have to be white. Vivian didn't particularly care about the color of her dress. I'm okay with it not being white, but I feel like it's going to raise some eyebrows from my older generations, my in-laws. I think when they see their kids getting married, they wanna see the white gown, and then they wanna share that moment. Because as much as people will say,
它必须是白色的，或者不一定非要是白色的。Vivian并不特别在意她婚纱的颜色。我不介意它不是白色的，但我觉得这会引起老一辈人，我公婆的侧目。我想当他们看到自己的孩子结婚时，他们想看到白色的礼服，然后他们想分享那个时刻。因为尽管人们会说，
it's the brides day. The day also belongs to everyone in the brides life, and there's only one dress. It has to represent tradition, but also be something unique and totally you. I always say, what do you like in your closet now? Elizabeth Thigh is a wedding dress designer. She says most of her clients start out thinking
这是新娘的日子。这一天也属于新娘生活中的每一个人，而且只有一件衣服。它必须代表传统，但也必须是独特且完全属于你的东西。我总是说，你现在衣柜里喜欢什么？Elizabeth Thigh是一位婚纱设计师。她说她的大多数客户开始时认为
they have no idea what they want in a wedding dress. But she says they can just look at what they already wear. But shape is it, but it feels like, just start with your relationship with clothing now. This is not a NASA space suit. This is not like a highly technical item of a peril. Like, you know how to do this. You may think you don't, but you know how.
她们根本不知道自己想要什么样的婚纱。但她说她们可以看看她们已经穿的衣服。但形状是什么，感觉是什么，从你现在与衣服的关系开始。这不是NASA的宇航服。这不是一件高科技的服装。就像，你知道怎么做。你可能认为你不知道，但你知道怎么做。
You have bought clothes, you have dressed yourself for years. But how can that translate to a wedding dress? Like, how could you, how could I be like? Every, you're wearing a V-neck. It's, this top looks like it might be vintage, is it? Yes. Okay, so, think about that. Is that a neckline that you like?
你买过衣服，你穿衣打扮已经很多年了。但这怎么能转化为婚纱呢？就像，你怎么能，我怎么能？你穿着一件V领。这件上衣看起来像是复古的，是吗？是的。好吧，那么，考虑一下。那是你喜欢的领口吗？
Do you like a loud print? Do you like the 60s? How do you like to feel? Do you like to wear a sleeve? Do you feel more comfortable in a sleeve? All of those things. I mean, clothing boils down to silhouette, textile, details. That's pretty much it.
你喜欢夸张的印花吗？你喜欢60年代的风格吗？你喜欢什么样的感觉？你喜欢穿袖子吗？你穿袖子感觉更舒服吗？所有这些事情。我的意思是，服装归根结底是廓形、面料、细节。基本上就是这样。
So shape, fabric, bits and pieces. So just think about what you gravitate towards in terms of shape, fabric, and bits and pieces. So sure, in some ways a wet ingress can be like other clothes you already have, but technically speaking, a wet ingress is like nothing else we have in our closets. I know I've never had anything tailored to my body. The vast majority of us now wear clothes with lycra in them and nets. And so things don't have to fit.
所以形状、面料、零碎的东西。所以只要想想你在形状、面料和细节方面倾向于什么。所以当然，在某些方面，婚纱可以像你已经拥有的其他衣服一样，但从技术上讲，婚纱与我们衣柜里的任何东西都不一样。我知道我从来没有穿过为我量身定做的衣服。我们现在绝大多数人穿的衣服里都有莱卡和网眼。所以衣服不需要合身。
They just have to stretch. So most of us are just not accustomed to wearing something that fits close to the body, like that is touching us, and that doesn't stretch. A wedding dress is a throwback to how clothing used to feel. It really brings up all of the traditional draping techniques and the internal corset and the fundamentals of couture design come into play in wedding dresses in a way that they don't with most other clothing.
它们只需要有弹性。所以我们大多数人都不习惯穿那种紧贴身体、触碰我们且没有弹性的衣服。婚纱是对过去服装感觉的一种回归。它确实带出了所有的传统垂坠技术，内部紧身胸衣和高级定制设计的基本原理在婚纱中发挥了作用，而这些在大多数其他服装中是没有的。
In a lot of ways, the typical wedding is a trip back to the times of Queen Victoria, overtly, if you're wearing white, but also in the very process of learning about this antiquated kind of clothing. I mean, having something called a gown rather than a dress or one, I mean, you know, it's a one and only gown, unless you get married again and then you get another gown. Most of us are not gown wearing very often. As Rebecca Meade wrote in her book, One Perfect Day, the process of wedding planning has become an Eliza
在很多方面，典型的婚礼是回到维多利亚女王时代的一次旅行，如果你穿白色，那是公开的，但也在学习这种过时服装的过程中。我的意思是，有一件被称为礼服而不是连衣裙的东西，我的意思是，你知道，这是一件独一无二的礼服，除非你再结婚，然后你再得到另一件礼服。我们大多数人并不经常穿礼服。正如Rebecca Meade在她的书《One Perfect Day》中所写，婚礼筹备的过程已经变成了一种伊莱扎
do little lake education. I went to these kind of wedding planning seminars where you would have experts instructing the brides to be on, make sure you practice walking backwards in your dress because if you don't, you're going to trip over the train and fall over and break your neck. And I mean, these are literally the things that were taught to Victorian maidens in finishing schools before they found their husbands. And this sort of education goes beyond the dress into the different kinds of cutlery and flower arrangements and varieties
杜利特尔式的教育。我参加了这些婚礼筹备研讨会，专家们指导准新娘们，确保你练习穿着婚纱向后走，因为如果你不这样做，你会被裙摆绊倒，摔倒并摔断脖子。我的意思是，这些确实是维多利亚时代的少女在找到丈夫之前在精修学校里被教导的事情。这种教育超越了婚纱，延伸到不同种类的餐具、花艺布置和各种
of buttercream and fondant, learning correct posture and how to walk. There's something incredibly retro, really, isn't that? And that's the whole point. We look back in time for reassurance, to understand that hundreds of thousands of people before us did it just this way. Tradition is like a good luck charm. It's a huge thing to get married. I mean, it's very understandable that we want our personal choices to feel like they have some cultural value that extends beyond us.
奶油和翻糖，学习正确的姿势和走路方式。这确实有些非常复古的东西，不是吗？这就是重点。我们回顾过去以寻求安慰，以了解在我们之前的成千上万的人就是这样做的。传统就像一个好运符。结婚是一件大事。我的意思是，我们希望我们的个人选择感觉像是有某种超越我们自身的文化价值，这是非常可以理解的。
And the challenge of a wedding from the dress to the menu, everything, it's about finding that balance between tradition and individuality. So not only are you navigating your desires with the desires of everyone around you, you are also considering the desires
而婚礼的挑战，从婚纱到菜单，一切，都是关于在传统和个性之间找到平衡。所以你不仅是在处理你的欲望和你周围每个人的欲望，你还在考虑
of everyone who came before you. We want to be individual at the same time. We don't want to be out there on our own. And this balancing act, Rebecca Meade says, has its own significance. Only a few generations ago, getting married was a massive, arguably traumatic life change. In one day, you would go from being a kid living in your parents' house to becoming a spouse of someone who you maybe didn't know that well And now when a lot of couples already live together and know all there is to know about each other
所有在你之前的人的欲望。我们想在同一时间保持个性。我们不想独自一人。Rebecca Meade说，这种平衡行为有其自身的意义。就在几代人之前，结婚是一次巨大的、可以说是创伤性的生活改变。在一天之内，你就会从一个住在父母家里的孩子变成一个你可能不太了解的人的配偶。而现在，当许多情侣已经住在一起并了解对方的一切时
We replicate that change that major feeling of transition in the act of planning the wedding the wedding Process substitutes for the shock that once you would have had, you know, going from being a single person to being a married person, and I think it's in a way it becomes a kind of useful thing to go through because you feel like it really, you know, there is something different happening to you. You have gone through the process of planning this thing. You've learned about floral arrangements and venue rentals. You've gone through low-stakes simulations of trials and tribulations.
我们在筹备婚礼的过程中复制了那种改变，那种重大的过渡感。婚礼过程取代了你曾经会有的那种冲击，你知道，从单身变成已婚人士，我认为在某种程度上，经历这个过程变成了一件有用的事情，因为你觉得它真的，你知道，确实有不同的事情发生在你身上。你经历了筹备这件事的过程。你了解了花艺布置和场地租赁。你经历了低风险的模拟考验和磨难。
And in this way, the ordeal of finding a wedding gown is particularly symbolic. You know, there's so much hope and promise that's caught up in the buying of the dress. I mean, the gown has a totemic quality, doesn't it? You know, you fall in love with the dress as a way of falling in love with your spouse or replicating that experience of falling in love.
通过这种方式，寻找婚纱的磨难尤其具有象征意义。你知道，购买婚纱的过程中蕴含着如此多的希望和承诺。我的意思是，礼服有一种图腾般的品质，不是吗？你知道，你爱上这件礼服，作为爱上你的配偶或复制那种坠入爱河的体验的一种方式。
And this is the one, you know, you've found the one just like you found the one to marry. I was so ready to follow my colleague Vivian to a local dress salon to watch that process unfold, where she would try on gown after gown, dancing and shimmying, and every look, while I sat on the couch giving my thumbs up or thumbs down, until Vivian comes out of the dressing room
这就是那一件，你知道，你找到了那一件，就像你找到了要结婚的那个人一样。我非常乐意跟随我的同事Vivian去当地的婚纱沙龙观看那个过程的展开，她会试穿一件又一件礼服，跳舞和扭动，每一个造型，而我坐在沙发上竖起大拇指或向下，直到Vivian走出更衣室
with an ethereal glow on her face. And everything seems to slow down. We don't have to say a word. We just know she's found the right one. The sales attendants clasp their hands over their mouths. And suddenly I'm crying. And Vivian is crying. We're all crying.
脸上带着空灵的光芒。一切似乎都慢了下来。我们不必说一句话。我们只是知道她找到了对的那一件。销售人员双手合十放在嘴边。突然我哭了。Vivian也哭了。我们都在哭。
And in this moment, we all truly understand the gravity of what Vivian is about to do. And we burst out in applause. But I don't have this moment on tape. It didn't happen. No, because I bought a dress, literally like probably two days after we talked. Inspired by our interview? A little bit. Like I think after we talked, I kind of wanted to get it done. So I went online, I just googled around. Vivian showed me a picture of a long white off the shoulder dress, very sleek. No lace or embellishment at all.
在这一刻，我们都真正理解了Vivian即将要做的事情的重要性。我们爆发出掌声。但我没有录下这一刻。它没有发生。不，因为我在我们谈话后大概两天就买了一件婚纱。受我们采访的启发？有一点。我想在我们谈话后，我有点想把它搞定。所以我上网，只是到处搜了搜。Vivian给我看了一张长款白色露肩婚纱的照片，非常时髦。没有任何蕾丝或装饰。
It's not poofy at all. It's just kind of a sleek material. So how much was your dress? If I can ask. Yeah, no, you can tell. I can tell you. It was $100. No. Yeah tell you. It was $100. No.
它一点也不蓬松。它只是一种时髦的材料。那你的婚纱多少钱？如果我可以问的话。是的，不，你可以说。我可以告诉你。它是100美元。不。是的，告诉你。它是100美元。不。
Yeah. What? It was $100. Is it nice? It's nice. It's not see-through. It might catch on fire in the sunlight. I haven't tried it on in sunlight yet.
是的。什么？它是100美元。它好看吗？它很好看。它不透。它可能会在阳光下着火。我还没在阳光下试穿过。
But I like it. And in a weird way, Viv is following Elizabeth's advice. She picked out a wedding dress, the same way she picks out the other clothes in her wardrobe. She found a bargain. The Maxinee's didn't mean what's again. And it's very much in Vivian's minimal sleek style. But it's also clearly a wedding dress.
但我喜欢它。以一种奇怪的方式，Viv遵循了Elizabeth的建议。她挑选婚纱的方式和她挑选衣柜里其他衣服的方式一样。她找到了一个便宜货。Maxinee的粉丝又一次证明了这一点。它非常符合Vivian极简时髦的风格。但它显然也是一件婚纱。
It's white, and it's not something Viv could just wear a second time without significant alterations. I think this is definitely the kind of cut and fit that if I wanted to die it and wear it to something else, I totally couldn't do that. It turns out this is a common fantasy about wedding dresses. I get asked quite often, could I just shorten this dress later if I want to wear it again, or could I die it?
它是白色的，如果不是经过重大修改，Viv不可能第二次穿它。我认为这绝对是那种如果我想把它染了穿去别的地方，我完全做不到的剪裁和合身度。事实证明，这是关于婚纱的一个常见幻想。我经常被问到，如果我想再穿一次，我可以把这件衣服改短吗，或者我可以把它染了吗？
Elizabeth die, the wedding dress designer. My last name is die. So if you want to die a wedding dress and you Google dye wedding dress, I come right up. And the answer to the question of, should you dye your wedding dress? Is no. Don't dye your wedding dress. The chances of you ruining it are like 95%. Even if you send it out to get it dyed professionally, it's tough.
Elizabeth Die，婚纱设计师。我的姓是Die。所以如果你想染婚纱，你在谷歌上搜索“染婚纱”，我就会直接出现。对于“你应该染你的婚纱吗？”这个问题的答案是：不。不要染你的婚纱。你毁了它的几率大概是95%。即使你把它送出去专业染色，也很难。
Because most garments are made of more than one textile, and they all take dyes differently, and often it comes out unevenly. Dye can also shrink garments. Just generally, it's a rough thing to put your dress through. I'm glad you told me that... now. Before I threw it in a bucket with some like... the color...
因为大多数服装是由不止一种面料制成的，它们对染料的吸收方式不同，而且通常染出来不均匀。染料也会使衣服缩水。总的来说，让你的婚纱经历这些是一件粗暴的事情。我很高兴你告诉我……现在。在我把它扔进桶里，加点……颜色之前……
Oh yeah, no. I have done that before with shorts. It was a pair of jorts that I turned into green jorts for anime expo, because I was cosplay. Who are you? I've got a lot of skeletons in my closet. So if you can't die and re-wear your dress, lots of brides are opting to do something unprecedented in the long history of wedding dresses.
哦，是的，不。我以前对短裤做过那种事。那是一条我为了动漫展改成绿色短裤的牛仔短裤，因为我在玩Cosplay。你是谁？我的衣柜里有很多秘密。所以如果你不能染和重穿你的婚纱，很多新娘选择做婚纱史上前所未有的事情。
They will take this gown that they spent countless hours fretting over and toss it. So, I've been making wedding dresses for a little over 15 years, which is crazy. It's literally a new generation getting married now. There's now sort of a new generation who grew up with fast fashion and just a really different relationship with clothes. There's much more of a, I just want to look killer on Instagram and then I'll piece out. There's actually a whole trend of theatrically destroying the dress after the wedding. Like the bride will jump in the ocean in the dress or get it covered in sand or set it
她们会把这件花了无数时间烦恼的礼服扔掉。所以，我制作婚纱已经超过15年了，这很疯狂。现在结婚的确实是新一代。现在有一代人是在快时尚中长大的，对衣服有着完全不同的关系。更多的是一种，我只想在Instagram上看起来很棒，然后我就不管了。实际上有一种在婚礼后戏剧性地销毁婚纱的趋势。比如新娘会穿着婚纱跳进海里，或者让它沾满沙子，或者把它点
on fire in order to take pictures of it. Trash the dress. Yes. That's what the trend is called. Yes. I would say that the trash the dress thing is in keeping with sort of this new idea of just like pure moment. And then if you want to extend the moment, extend the moment by just destroying the thing
着火，为了拍照片。毁掉婚纱。是的。这就是那个趋势的名字。是的。我想说，毁掉婚纱这件事符合那种关于纯粹时刻的新想法。然后如果你想延长那个时刻，通过销毁那件东西来延长那个时刻
and making sure to get like incredible photos of that, and then you're done. There's something kind of poetic about finding beauty in this destruction. Trash the dress is kind of like an anti-saromone in some ways. But I don't know, maybe instead of submerging it in an ocean or setting it on fire or attempting to die at green, maybe the dress itself can function like a photograph. Maybe it's worth keeping a wedding dress in your closet to remind you of that one day that you worked so hard for. I guess I could give it away, but I had some sentimental value to me. Alice in Cherneau has held on to her wedding dress for 30 years. I don't have much else left over from the wedding,
并确保拍出那种令人难以置信的照片，然后你就完成了。在这种破坏中寻找美有一种诗意。毁掉婚纱在某些方面有点像反仪式。但我不知道，也许与其把它淹没在海里或点火，或者试图把它染成绿色，也许婚纱本身可以像照片一样发挥作用。也许把婚纱留在衣柜里提醒你那一天你付出的努力是值得的。我想我可以把它送人，但它对我有一些情感价值。Alice in Cherneau已经保留她的婚纱30年了。我没有从婚礼中剩下太多其他东西，
you know, other than the album and all that's been to. Ha ha ha. Alison is my mom. She has the album full of photos, the videos, the wedding ring, and what's more, me and my sister. There's a lot of evidence that she got married to my dad, but to her, the dress is different somehow.
你知道，除了相册和所有那些。哈哈。Alison是我妈妈。她有装满照片的相册、视频、结婚戒指，更重要的是，我和我姐姐。有很多证据表明她嫁给了我爸爸，但对她来说，婚纱以某种方式是不同的。
So I can look at this, I can look at even looking at the photos, I sort of start thinking about the friends or the people who've died since the bed of my wedding, things like that. But this is the only object that really makes me think about the actual event and the ceremony. I can then remember how I felt in the dress and how I felt that day. I did feel really beautiful. I felt like that was my day and people stood up when I walked on the aisle in that dress
所以我可以看着这个，我甚至可以看着照片，我开始想到那些在我婚礼之后去世的朋友或人们，诸如此类的事情。但这是唯一让我想到实际事件和仪式的物品。然后我可以记住我在婚纱里的感觉以及那天我的感觉。我确实感觉非常漂亮。我觉得那是我的日子，当我在那件婚纱里走过过道时，人们站了起来
and you felt very special. It was a moment. I'm kind of an awe of people who decide to get married. Becoming legally bound to someone else seems so recklessly optimistic it's almost rebellious. And not just because there's a 40% chance it won't work out. Through the bubonic plague and the Great Depression and the coronavirus, people have found ways to get married, to have whatever version of a wedding they can, for richer or for poorer, in sickness and in health.
你感觉非常特别。那是一个时刻。我有点敬畏那些决定结婚的人。在法律上与另一个人结合似乎如此鲁莽地乐观，几乎是叛逆的。不仅仅是因为有40%的可能性它不会成功。通过黑死病、大萧条和冠状病毒，人们找到了结婚的方法，以他们能拥有的任何形式的婚礼，无论贫穷还是富有，无论健康还是疾病。
Weddings are easy to lampoon, I don't need to go through the reasons why. But at the heart of this cliche is something vulnerable, and at the heart of all this luxury is something necessary. It's about having something to reach for, having something to feel excited about. It actually is a special day. Like I was kind of avoiding coming in terms with that it's a special day that people want to be happy for you. The wedding dress became an afterthought after having experienced, you know, being around family and getting to live these three very distinct weddings. Vivian had her weddings. The Italian getaway with the sleek off the shoulder dress. And it was perfect. The courthouse and Los Angeles. I got like a 40-buck dress. So that was fine. And the big family gathering in New York. Thin-strapped, floor-length, lacy.
婚礼很容易被讽刺，我不需要列举原因。但在这种陈词滥调的核心是某种脆弱的东西，而在所有这些奢侈的核心是某种必要的东西。这是关于拥有可以追求的东西，拥有可以感到兴奋的东西。这确实是一个特别的日子。就像我一直在避免接受这是一个特别的日子，人们想为你感到高兴。在经历了，你知道，在家人身边并能够经历这三场非常独特的婚礼之后，婚纱成了事后才想到的事情。Vivian举行了她的婚礼。意大利之旅，穿着时髦的露肩婚纱。这很完美。洛杉矶的法院。我买了一件40美元的婚纱。所以那很好。还有在纽约的大家庭聚会。细肩带，落地长裙，蕾丝。
And I've seen a million girls with, you know, the same exact wedding dress, and it didn't bother me. And then suddenly, all that energy and anxiety that went into the dresses went away. It was like Cinderella's carriage turning back into a pumpkin. The dresses are just dresses. I could let it go, I feel like.
我见过一百万个女孩穿着，你知道，完全一样的婚纱，这并没有困扰我。然后突然，投入到婚纱里的所有精力和焦虑都消失了。就像灰姑娘的马车变回了南瓜。婚纱只是婚纱。我觉得我可以放手了。
Yeah? Yeah, I think so. I don't know. I think we keep too much stuff. You know, like I don't wanna end up hoarding all these clothes. Really? You'd be okay with not having any. I haven't felt the need to take out the wedding dresses
是吗？是的，我想是的。我不知道。我觉得我们保留了太多东西。你知道，我不想最后囤积所有这些衣服。真的吗？你没问题吗？我没感觉到需要拿出婚纱
and like look at them and like feel them again or put them on again. Also it just happened. It just happened. It could, yeah, 10 years from now I might want to have one. Or even 30 years from now. I don't even know if it would fit. It's so funny to try on.
然后像看它们，再次感受它们或再次穿上它们。而且它刚刚发生。它刚刚发生。它可能，是的，10年后我可能想拥有一件。甚至30年后。我甚至不知道它是否合身。试穿它太有趣了。
You want to try it? Yeah, I'll try it on. Yeah. Because clothes are records of the bodies we've lived in. We are like snakes who shed our skins and acquire new ones as we age. Oh, I remember this. The waist is so narrow. But sometimes it's nice in the churn of our clothes
你想试试吗？是的，我会试穿。是的。因为衣服是我们生活过的身体的记录。我们就像蛇，随着年龄的增长蜕皮并获得新的皮肤。哦，我记得这个。腰部太窄了。但有时在衣服的更迭中
to let something last. I'm just kidding, dude. No. Because the way you change and grow might be unexpected. Because your shoulders are bright. My shoulders got big. I got rough. But in this case, when I tried on my mom's blood and dress, I don't think it'll button. And couldn't get it off. I shouldn't have done this. I'm sorry. I had to rip the dress she'd been saving for three decades. But the just go for it. Okay. But the bright side of this was that with a newly ripped open scene.
让某些东西持久一点是很好的。我只是开玩笑，伙计。不。因为你改变和成长的方式可能是意想不到的。因为你的肩膀变宽了。我的肩膀变大了。我变粗壮了。但在这种情况下，当我试穿我妈妈的婚纱时，我不认为它能扣上。而且脱不下来。我不该这么做。对不起。我不得不撕开她保存了三十年的婚纱。但只要去做就行了。好的。但好的一面是，随着新撕开的接缝。
Yeah, she's pretty good. My mom's wedding dress could actually fit her again. Oh, hey! Aha, see? I'm glad I kept it. She hadn't worn it in years. And there, with her two grown-up daughters watching. Wait, where's Dad? An address that wasn't quite her size or her style anymore.
是的，她很不错。我妈妈的婚纱实际上又能穿在她身上了。哦，嘿！啊哈，看？我很高兴我保留了它。她已经很多年没穿过它了。在那里，在她的两个成年女儿的注视下。等等，爸爸在哪？一件不再是她尺寸或风格的婚纱。
She walked through her home. Check it out. And all eyes were on her. Look at the birds. Again. Unbelievable. unbelievable There's a portrait painted on the things we love Bring cold on this plane A feather like an engine that's here The language's no way There's a picture printed on the things we love
她走过她的家。看看这个。所有的目光都集中在她身上。看那些鸟。再一次。难以置信。难以置信。在我们爱的事物上画着一幅肖像。在这个平面上变冷。像引擎一样的羽毛在这里。语言没有办法。在我们爱的事物上印着一张照片。
A pocket, a piece of paper, Words run yesterday There's a portrait painted on the things that we love. Articles of Interest was written and performed by Avery Truffleman, edited by Chris Brube with additional edits by Emmett Fitzgerald and Joe Rosenberg, scored by Ray Royal and Sean Raell with additional music by Jason Ja, fact checked by Tom Colligan with additional fact checking by Graham Haysha, mix and tech production by Sharif Yusef with additional fact-checking by Graham Haysha. Mix and Tech production by Shereef Yusef with additional mixing by Catherine Raimondo. Our opening and closing songs are by the mighty Sasami. Her self-titled album is so beautiful and she's a single out called MESS. Check her out.
一个口袋，一张纸，昨天的话语。在我们爱的事物上画着一幅肖像。《Articles of Interest》由Avery Truffleman撰写和表演，Chris Brube编辑，Emmett Fitzgerald和Joe Rosenberg进行了额外编辑，Ray Royal和Sean Raell配乐，Jason Ja提供了额外音乐，Tom Colligan进行了事实核查，Graham Haysha进行了额外事实核查，Sharif Yusef进行了混音和技术制作，Catherine Raimondo进行了额外混音。我们的开场和结束歌曲由强大的Sasami演唱。她的同名专辑非常美丽，她有一首名为MESS的单曲。去看看她。
Insight, support, and edits from the whole 99PI team, including Vivian Leish, Henrialle, Abby Madon, Kurt Colstead, Delaney Hall, and Katie Mingle. And Roman Mars is the best man of this whole series. And that's it. That was articles of interest in its entirety because it is with a heavy heart and much, much gratitude. But I'm leaving 99% invisible. It's been nearly seven incredible years since Roman Mars took a chance on an intern fresh out of college and kickstarted my career. Literally his kickstarter campaign got me hired.
来自整个99PI团队的见解、支持和编辑，包括Vivian Leish, Henrialle, Abby Madon, Kurt Colstead, Delaney Hall和Katie Mingle。Roman Mars是整个系列的伴郎。就是这样。这就是《Articles of Interest》的全部内容，因为我怀着沉重的心情和非常非常多的感激之情。但我正在离开99% Invisible。距离Roman Mars冒险录用一个刚毕业的实习生并开启我的职业生涯已经过去了近七个不可思议的年头。字面上，他的Kickstarter活动让我被录用了。
And 99% invisible hasn't just shaped the way I make radio. It's changed my philosophy on the built environment and the things people make and use. So thank you, thank you, thank you for filling my world with wonder. Thank you specifically to Chris Brube, Katie Mingle, Kurt Colstad, John Rial, Delaney Hall, Sharif Yusef, Emmett Fitzgerald, Vivian Leigh, Joe Rosenberg, and most of all, Roman Mars. I am so lucky to have learned from all of your brilliance.
99% Invisible不仅塑造了我制作广播的方式。它改变了我对建筑环境以及人们制造和使用的事物的哲学。所以谢谢，谢谢，谢谢你们让我的世界充满了奇迹。特别感谢Chris Brube, Katie Mingle, Kurt Colstad, John Rial, Delaney Hall, Sharif Yusef, Emmett Fitzgerald, Vivian Leigh, Joe Rosenberg，最重要的是，Roman Mars。我非常幸运能从你们所有人的才华中学习。
I am so lucky to have learned from all of your brilliance. And thank you, dear listener, for coming along for the ride. It's truly a luxury to be heard. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我非常幸运能从你们所有人的才华中学习。也谢谢你，亲爱的听众，陪伴我走过这段旅程。被倾听确实是一种奢侈。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。